here is a bombshell story Donald Trump
has a hotel in Azerbaijan that is just
about done it's called the Trump
International Hotel and Tower in Baku
and Donald Trump's FEC financial
disclosure report showed that he's
already earned almost three million
dollars from this project that I'm
showing you if you're watching along
with me Ivanka Trump Trump's daughter
has visited the building and posted
about it on Instagram she posted a video
about oh she's just so excited about it
there's an asura by Johnny lawyer
involved with the project who said that
the Trump Organization has been very
hands-on with this project right down to
the smallest details and now the
building is in the final stages of
construction it even has furniture
inside according to some reports but it
hasn't opened right why hasn't it opened
I think you're gonna like this when
Donald Trump won the election he shut
the whole thing down because he thought
that having his name on the building
might look sort of shady why would it
look shady you might ask
because Donald Trump had been developing
the property in partnership with
azerbaijan's
power family the mama dogs here's Ivanka
Trump with one of the family members for
our television and YouTube audience the
mama dogs are notorious for exploiting
Azerbaijani politicians for personal
gain and this is where it gets very
interesting Pat just put a seatbelt on
he's ready to go with this this mama dog
family has close ties to the Iranian
Islamic Revolutionary Guard Corps which
is an extremist militia in Iran that
enforces a claw in the country it's one
of the most extreme factions okay
this was the same group the IRGC that
was controlling the construction of
donald trump's hotel in azerbaijan and
jessica dilip man who's an expert on
anti-government corruption at George
Washington University Law School said
quote the entire Baku deal is a giant
red flag the direct involvement
of foreign government officials and
their relatives in Azerbaijan with ties
to the Iranian Revolutionary Guard
corruption warning signs are rarely more
obvious the IRGC helps finance Iran's
nuclear weapons program the IRGC trained
terrorist organizations like Hezbollah
things that Donald Trump's quite house
claims to be against and and this is
where I mean I know I say this to you
about you can't write this stuff the
White House the Trump White House is
currently trying to classify the IRGC as
a terrorist organization okay let's step
back for a second here to sum it up
Donald Trump was indirectly working with
a group to build his building in
Azerbaijan which is a group that the
White House considers to be a terrorist
organization but in fairness to Trump he
did sort of accidentally admit to Hugh
Hewitt on his radio show that he had
never heard of the Kurds forces who are
the sort of Special Ops unit of the IRGC
so maybe it's it's ignorance rather than
corruption here's a reminder of that are
you familiar with general Soleimani
uh-huh yes I go ahead give me a little
go ahead tell me yeah he runs the Kurds
forces yes okay but do you expected by
the way have been hotly mistreated by
the Kurds forces the Iranian
Revolutionary Guards could yeah right so
our president has done business with a
corrupt family that deals with
terrorists but he may be so ignorant of
world affairs that he might not even
have known that at the time I'm not sure
which of these ideas is scarier that
there's possible completely rampant
corruption with terrorist groups or the
definitive ignorance that Donald Trump
has demonstrated time and again it's
things like this that would leave a
distinct long lasting stain on any other
presidency Pat but somehow with Trump
because it's 20 scandals a week this
isn't even being mentioned by many many
programs and media outlets but let's
distract from this the Kurds have been
treated so unfairly yes absolutely
wait the crew brought up the Kurds
doesn't matter Trump wants to talk about
curds he heard kids doesn't know what
that is but curds it sounds similar
maybe he can repeat a talking point he
got off of Fox and Friends and probably
misunderstood off of Fox and Friends
absolutely and utterly stunning send me
your thoughts about this I'm on Twitter
at D Pakman the show is on Twitter at
David Pakman show we'll be back after
this